we also made a decision that to attract
new customers to this space you had to
look and feel and talk to the customers
like you're an airline booking had to be
similar uh the process had to be simple
yet it give a price that wasn't variable
on how how long the flight's going to
take it's just a fixed price that was
new to the business now everybody's
doing that but that was very new to the
business when we watched
so we want to look and feel like an
airline but we are not giving you the
airline experience because you get to
choose the time you want to go where you
want to go and there's you know not
there's no long lines at the airport to
get you know get out in the plane
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by J Ventures a
Community Driven VC Fund in celkon
Valley in partnership with low me Tech
sponsored by Homeward Ventures hippo
Insurance Upper slabs Synergy Global
hello Stanford leap Birthright Excel
Sereno partners and in media partnership
with ctec
foreign
ERS today I'm with Andrew schmertz the
CEO of hopscotch air an FAA Certified
Air Taxi operator Hopscotch air is a
transformative air carrier delivering
private Aviation at affordable prices he
is a frequent commentator on Aviation
and small business issues and previously
was a contributor to PBS NewsHour and an
anchor of the businessweek TV show
Andrew Schwartz welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for being here
how are you
I'm good Michael and thank you for
having me looking forward to the talk
oh I am so looking forward to it we're
going to be talking about one of our
exciting industries that we have in the
world today literally Air Taxi
operations which is you know it's I'm
astounded that we're actually sitting
here talking about it and I'm
introducing it as a sort of a category
and it's something that you know we're
already talking about and really is a
transforming our world and so I'm
excited to talk to you as the CEO of
hopscotch air and you have quite a quite
a quite an interesting background
besides error taxing which I'm excited
to learn about as well and and so we're
going to be spending these next
tournamental dive into your world and
your passion so again thank you very
much for being here what is it between
you and planes or flying things
well um so first let me start by saying
I think the word passion is misused in
business let's say the word passion for
the bedroom uh I think it's about
dedication and force of will to get
through the daily challenges especially
in the airline industry where there's
still where there's hourly challenges
often the same challenges at the same
time every single day and by having that
dedication and that force of will you
project that onto your employees onto
your partners onto your customers and
onto your vendors and that's really key
when You Face challenges they will all
rally around and support the business my
personal story with airplanes about it
about a dozen years ago I you know I was
a Private Pilot just flying around
recreationally and my business partner
so I went to college with and I decided
you know we looked at the environment we
looked at the aviation space and that
environment and decided that this
category is one that we could enter and
we can grow and we could eventually
Dominate and therefore I shifted my
career I was working in media I was a
television reporter here in New York
City for a number of years and that that
helps in this business as well because
it helps with marketing uh I'm an
attorney as well that can't hurt uh
though I don't like to talk about being
that too much uh but we decided to
launch uh this new type of of industry
and we
certified the airline from the ground up
we worked diligently with the FAA that's
unusual many companies buy an air
certificate or many companies broker out
flights but don't actually operate the
aircraft we operate the aircraft and
it's a branded operation every one of
our planes has our name on it all the
pilots where Hopscotch air shirts and
that's unusual in the on-demand private
Aviation Space
I love it I love the background and I
love the sort of the way that you're
framing the way that the space looks
tell me a little bit about private
um you know private flying and the air
attacks the operations is this a new
phenomena is this a growing phenomena
what's happening around the world with
this so it's kind of a split phenomenon
you could always show up to the airport
and find somebody to fly you somewhere
so there's always been a private
Aviation component especially here in
the United States uh I know in Tel Aviv
Israel did private Aviation is also
growing and it's growing throughout
Africa by by also I have Private Pilot
here but it's uh but no but I haven't
yet flown people yeah well I flew
friends but I haven't flown commercial
yet I'll ask you the typical question
what planes do you fly
I assess no 172. okay I know it well
it's a great play so yes uh on on the
what what we've done is we were looking
at a market of how to expand the number
of people who could fly on a private
aircraft because as you know a small
percentage of the population that can
afford to fly privately ever does and
what we developed is a regional
on-demand air taxi service we never used
the word charter we are technically a
charter company by regulation but we
never use the word charter because
Charter suggests that Kim Kardashian is
going to get on the plane and you're
gonna have champagne and caviar none of
that we provide a utilitarian service
and we do that by flying small piston
aircraft serious aircraft four-seater
aircraft playing with the parachute may
have seen it and we fly on Regional
routes
largely in New York so our biggest route
is is New York let's say Westchester
County to Nantucket and we serve a
customer base that's both Leisure
customers and business customers so
let's say you need to fly to Ithaca and
that's about an hour and a half flight
no about an hour and 10 minute flight
from New York and come back for your
son's soccer game at night you can do
that with Hopscotch air and you could do
that at a price point that is about
two-thirds less than traditional Charter
flying so we're really we're really
competing against the car
because you could drive everywhere we
fly to so we're competing against the
car
and we're competing against the regional
Airlines which in the United States the
regional Airlines have have largely
collapsed over the past couple of years
well so how how do you actually you know
operate as a business I'm still you know
this is a it seems like it's a
it's a it's really interesting for me
that as an entrepreneur thinking about
what it's like to run it and there and
and they're attacking business just
because it's
it just just sounds different it's hard
to explain even why no you know it is
different and it's exciting so you know
when I show up to a bar and talking to
somebody they all want to talk about
flying it's certainly an excitement to
the Aviation Space yeah the business how
to run the business is we made some
strategic decisions early on we were
going to be a branded operation which
means that all of our customers are our
customers we're not relying on Brokers
to give us the flight so about 95 of our
customers are organic they're all
homegrown by us we are also heavily
marketed we believe in marketing uh
aggressively and with a sales force that
is different than the traditional
charter company so we really believe
we're running an airline we also made a
decision that to attract new customers
to this space you had to look and feel
and talk to the customers like you're an
airline booking had to be similar the
process had to be well you had to give a
price that wasn't variable interesting
how how long the flight's going to take
it's just a fixed price that was new to
the business now everybody's doing that
but that was very new to the business
when we launched
so we want to look and feel like an
airline but we are not giving you the
airline experience because you get to
choose the time you want to go where you
want to go and there's you know not
there's no long lines at the airport to
get you know to get out in the plane
I want to defer on this point first
thing because this is it's a really
interesting one so I would assume that
part of the magic of you know going
through a service like Hopscotch air is
the fact that you don't have the
traditional you know Airline experience
of booking and then some like I can I
can intuitively assess why you know you
why you found that to be impactful but
but I'd love to hear it from you you
know what was what were sort of the key
understandings from a consumer Behavior
standpoint that made it clear to you
that that this is how the the framing
should be on in the messaging
ease of use so if you were to Charter an
aircraft in the United States it's not
an easy process you probably need your
executive assistant to pick up the phone
and call a multiple number of Brokers
get a number of quotes in and then you
kind of decide which one you want that
was not the system we were aiming for we
were talking not just to Executive
systems but we're talking to the actual
passengers who are flying on our planes
and they want easy some systems they
wanted to know they want to know are you
available and how much it's going to
cost me and those two answers derive
whether people will book and of course
they ask safety questions too uh which
which we can very easily answer so the
the the customer typically wants to know
those three components but by the time
they get to the safety question
uh and you know most customers who fly
for the first time ask questions about
the pilot about the plane what's your
safety protocols by the time they get to
that question we know they will book and
we know they will book because we've
already provided them that yes we can do
the flight and here's the price so it's
ease of use we want to reduce the
friction
in the business there's too much
friction in private Aviation right now
all right how do you build that trust
with the customer when I go on the big
plane and I see those little fancy
Pilots that are you know there there's a
lot of Swag and there's a lot of
prestige and I and I feel important that
I'm getting on this big big flying bird
it feels very safe right I know that I
had to to explain to my passengers you
know exactly what's going to happen
because that plane is small and it's
gonna shake and you feel the turbulence
and you hear the engine pretty loud
right and so how how do you what what is
sort of the process that you go through
to build this trust with new consumers
because once you get on it the first
time it's beautiful
that's right so so that's exactly right
so first the Cirrus is not a
particularly uh turbulent aircraft it's
it's very stable in the air yeah but it
is exactly what you just said it's the
first time experience to determine
whether they come back and whether they
feel that you're trustworthy so there's
two Avenues of trust safety and whether
you can deliver the service that they're
expecting on that ladder Point uh we
need to always do better because we're
in a business where we land turn and go
we are flying these aircraft every hour
during you know 12 hours a day for
example we are there there they're
always on the move that results in
delays so you want to be on time you
want to provide the service that people
expect that they're going to get for the
price points they're going to get the
safety aspect
it comes down to how the pilots present
themselves
the uh safety procedures that we have in
place the pre-flight briefings for
example you know you get into your
system 172 you could just decide to go
fly that's not Hopscotch air we're
operating a much higher level of safety
in that we have multiple people along
the chain that can stop a flight at any
time so any flight can't go without our
chief pilot or director of operations or
one of their designaties determining
that the flight can be saved that's from
a weather standpoint that's from an
airport standpoint that's from a weight
and balance standpoint you know if if
four or three hundred pound people show
up in the slico so there's multiple
redundancies which we follow closely and
that increases the envelope for safety
because we are flying in very
challenging weather we're doing a number
of flights every day especially in the
summer down to minimums you know we're
going down to 200 feet
on approaches so we need to have that
all buttoned up
yeah okay what's the vision here of
hopscotch air
so the vision has always been and it got
curtailed during covet certainly the
vision has always been we believe that
we can put a hundred of these aircraft
in the Northeast alone and in the summer
fly them every day we also believe it's
a nationwide product that it can work in
any Market in the United States even in
areas like North Dakota where the
weather is poor so the goal and the
vision of the company really is not just
to provide a quote alternative because I
hate that word to airline travel but to
provide a new option for people in their
flight uh in their travel profile
right and so if you're if you're taking
this one step further and you're
thinking about you know the way that
this impacts you know customers are you
imagining this is becoming a more you
know if you're if we're looking even
more generally at the industry is
becoming a more mainstream event is this
thing with a specific demographic that's
because a lot of people are talking
about air taxis as you know becoming
something somewhat of a more you know
Common phenomenon I know it in the
United Arab Emirates they're talking a
lot about this you know you're living
the industry well what are you
experiencing there in terms of the
consumers yeah and by the way we've had
a number of talks with uh members at the
UAE about this our experience is that
the regional travel uh business needs to
be solved in the United States so
there's no good train service in this
country this Amtrak will take you to New
York to Boston but if you're traveling
anywhere else you know from New York to
Boston New York to Washington the train
Services is spotty the roads the
infrastructure all right is is a
disaster right so there's all this
effort to fix the rows so the real
solution is air travel and that's why
you're seeing a number of companies with
these EV talls electric knee talls uh
but I don't personally believe the
battery power is going to be there for a
decade or so so you need Solutions
to take people off the road
that is where the real environmental
impact is happening in this country is
that there's too many cars on the road
uh and stuck in traffic and polluting
that the polluting all the air that
solution can be resolved through travel
to air travel
got it
tell me a little bit about your and I'm
going back to that initial question and
you know to show it then it's all about
you know leadership and and why you do
what you do
why do you do what you do
it's a very good question because there
are a lot of easier ways to make money
I'll tell you that uh there are there is
the dedication and the drive to to build
a business because of my connection to
Aviation this is a space that interests
me uh when we talk to shareholders and
when we talk to potential investors we
say that this is a market that can grow
and can be profitable it is not going to
be a tech company though because you
can't scale it like a tech company then
you need airplanes and you need pilots
and there's there's there's a shortage
of both right now and so we need to
resolve those issues I also enjoy the
challenge so the challenge is really
kind of what gets me up in the morning I
like problems and there's problems every
day it's kind of a you kind of wake up
and it's a jigsaw puzzle and all the
pieces are all spread out all over the
floor every morning you put the thing
together piece by piece by piece and
then at night you know your dog wrecks
the whole thing and you have to start
all over again I enjoy that and as even
though you Tire in doing that and you
need to hire and work with great people
who can support you but I enjoy that
process
well what is the biggest challenge that
you're experiencing perhaps in the day
today if there is one big one is it a
bunch of small ones is a business owner
of such a company
uh there's both big ones and small ones
uh the big one right now is the problem
that all airlines are facing which is
there's a worldwide pilot shortage and
it's really come home to roost it's been
in the making for more than a decade but
now if you want to be a pilot and you
are a pilot you can write your own
ticket literally however it's a long
process the process is not going to get
solved tomorrow because Pilots need to
go through a lot of training we have to
have a certain number of hours so that
that that is a limiting factor on any
business is Can you hire enough crew
members to conduct flights that's the
big picture uh problem the other
challenges will include regulations
those regulatory challenges all the time
but we we meet that those challenges and
you know every day run-of-the-mill
business challenges uh in competition
you know when people when when you talk
with people and and they say well you
know I I can drive uh I there's cheaper
options of getting there so there's all
those challenges uh challenges occur in
the United States right now we have a
challenge that the airports that we
reach largely operate out of and we
could fly into any big airport we fly
into JFK LaGuardia Tel Aviv all the time
not telling Thief but the um
uh the the real challenge is at the
airport space there's not enough
concrete uh so yeah so the the the in
the the space of the airports is
becoming a challenge as well
I love it and if you are looking at
yourself from it from a leadership
perspective what is it like being a
leader of an organization that is doing
what you're doing I mean you're leading
pilot which uh you know I remember when
we were almost like the theory
theoretical work on pilot you know they
say you know it's like 70 of the errors
are human errors right when it comes to
deposit and and the other thing that was
a pretty remarkable was there was a
question at least in the Israeli ones
what are the most you know the most
common traits for a pilot and and one of
them was sort of like this know-it-all
mentality which I think that sort of
makes sense in a lot of ways but well so
so how do you lead you know with a group
that it perhaps is a little bit more
difficult to lead uh you proved to them
that you're smarter than they are
yeah it is a challenge it is a challenge
pilots pilots are certainly a little bit
cocky uh they are highly trained
professionals they are excellent at
their jobs but I also know pilots who
are excellent you know stick and Rudder
pilots and you can trust them with your
family uh but they can't tie their
shoelaces outside of the airplane you
read by you lead by providing a culture
a good culture a culture of respect
I say to every pilot who comes into the
organization let me know what else you
want to do in this business because
there's a number of other things so if
you don't want to be a pilot at the end
of the day maybe we can maybe you can do
a different job we want to have and show
respect to all members of the of the
Hopscotch Air Team and it is about
building a culture that is sustainable
and that's where the airlines failed
over the last decade and a half or so
their culture was we're gonna pay you
and you're gonna show up and do a job
and when feel prizes go up we're gonna
fire you that was the culture there was
very little investment in the pilots and
they're end up paying the price for that
now because Pilots Stop Being Pilots
right they and they stop meeting new
pilots so I'm and that and that is true
with any business you need to establish
a good culture one where there's respect
where there's understanding where you
pay well and we pay pretty well for our
size company and our side is aircraft
but we can't compete with Delta Airlines
of course so we expect Pilots to stay 18
months and then move on that's fine
because we want them happy because they
will refer their friends who are coming
up in the ranks to our company and
building us building a a culture is is
essential it's also essential from a
safety standpoint you need to have a
culture of safety so you have to empower
a pilot to never be afraid to cancel a
flight
wonderful
amazing journey Andrews that's such a
cool job that you have really thank you
thank you so much for coming here for
these 20 minutes I really appreciate it
I I wishing wishing you best of luck
with this journey and and I'm looking
forward to cheering from the side so
thank you very very much and stay safe
and stay out come to New York come to
New York and we'll go flying
thank you Michael coming to New York in
five I'm coming to New York in six days
this is on record we're going fly
looking forward to it Angel I'll see you
right there okay oh thank you very much
thank you